and i'm i'm gonna tell you that i have a
deep set
a deep depression to set in i woke up
today i'm like should i shoot heroin
today
no and luckily some magical things
happened
all right i got these listen where is it
frontier sonitsuka tigers i ordered
these
tigers online
like and i forgot i ordered them and i
got them today
and it made me happy and then you know
how your
friend of me your friend of me you know
how a friend of me gives you a gift
wait what what would you um what would
you
um how would you define a friend of me i
know but many people define it different
ways yeah
my a friend of me for me is somebody
that i for me
i want i don't want to like i don't want
to be friends with why wouldn't you want
to be friends
just everything about them ideologically
ethically you know i mean it's just
you're opposed to a local being their
whole being in essence
you know what i mean on on paper and
you know on paper it's like if i wrote
read it
yeah like in a magazine somebody's
characteristics
i would be like nah right but for some
reason
because of happenstance and
life you know i mean you you meet them
in a certain you know a venue or light
and you become friends with them
but you don't know why but you love them
but you don't want to and but
i do i love them do you have loyalty
towards the front of me
oh yeah i die for him okay so people
love that stuff
i would die for him i would die from
more of a friend than a me
no enemy still war brothers oh that that
that's a good one
that's a very good one so you and i are
on the same team or yeah or no i look at
it this way
it's like enemy mine do you ever see
that movie what is that no
it was a movie it was about um i forgot
who it was but it was
um a white dude and an alien trapped on
an island
on a planet deserted real movie it's a
real
movie i better not be the alien yeah
you're the alien right
and they're i guess you know humans and
this alien race
i don't forget the premise i'm sure
that's what it is and they were at war
and then these two um get just trapped
on an island a deserted island and they
have to become friends
to survive do they become friends yeah
these are sucking each other's dicks
it's
[ __ ] weird not really but you know
what i mean but um
so that's what it is i think it's is
there a movie called enemy mind
uh enemy it would bring me so much joy
if you just made that up
yes yes and is there is luke gossip jr
in it
he is he's the alien right yes yeah they
made the black guy they are alien
which is wrong well then and who's the
white guy then it's quite
dennis quaid then it's quite like so
yeah yeah yeah yeah so dennis quaid and
luke
gossip jr on an island an island why do
you keep saying island
a planet it's a planet it's a planet my
bad right so that's me and george
so george got me these shoes these you
know i've been you know sometimes he
wears
pretty cool shoes and i always go um
where'd you get those shoes
and he goes uh he tells me and then i'm
just too lazy
where i forget and so he bought me these
and they're pretty nice so thank you so
much
and you know it's it's you know normally
uh it would be very difficult for me to
accept them
but um i will accept them because i'm
changing my attitude toward
the people around me and that's what
growth is all about vibram bottoms
yeah these are fiber and bottoms but
thank you so much because it was a
surprise i never thought that you would
ever do this
but i feel like you you did this you
know i mean
for you you're expecting something in
return is it
be honest with me no because what you
said when you gave it to me goes
you then i go well that's weird you got
me this what do you want you guys
well i did write a script i have a movie
script is that what you said you wrote a
movie script i've always got a movie
screen
i said it as a joke and then you then
you asked me like do you yeah of course
i do
let me say something yeah george is an
amazing writer
i know he's like he's like he's a
legitimate amazing writer i've read so
much
so many of his stuff and i'm like in
terms of writers it goes
aaron sorkin and then george campbell
where's always what about andres what
andres andres is third for sure yeah
i um one of the days that you helped him
out
with um uh theo and um
um jay um he came back upstairs
and he was like babe you can never ever
repeat this to anyone okay
never never then don't say this don't if
i [ __ ] that don't say it no [ __ ]
it's benign it's not gonna it it might
ruin me
it may but it won't oh yeah i think it's
okay go ahead
because you can never tell anybody this
i was like okay fine what is it
that was the edge of my seat he was like
i
really really really love jewelry i
never
said that i never said that i believe it
i never why would i say that because
you're you're smiling angry
you're doing angry smiles no i'm not
angry this is how i'm i'm really angry
are you smirking a little bit because
i'm depressed yeah
he said he's never not there for me wow
yeah okay why are you frustrated it's
great it's not great
i hate it i hate it it's like having
it's like having rape juice on me oh
yeah i don't like rape
i don't even know what that is i don't
know i know because i never near it
your mind imagine what rape juices i
don't try to yeah yeah
it's like you know the residual effects
of rape yeah so enemy mind came out in
uh yeah yeah so um
you know i might have said that right
but i might have said that but the
things that you're
reading from me george yeah where you
you think because there are times where
i know you think oh he's in a bad mood
is does he not like me do you ever think
that do i think are you in a bad mood
a lot of the time i know i know but but
i know but do you ever think
that's communicate but do you ever think
do you ever think that i don't like you
not genuinely no damn it
it's not coming through the hatred yeah
i wanna i'm gonna ask you guys this
who do you think is in a bad mood more
often bobby or me
hmm i would it's tough
thank you it's tough oh god bless you i
have to be honest though
yeah like today you're in a good mood
even though you're depressed i don't
know why yeah
i think mood and depression is different
but we
base how to